Hello guys, Chris here. Welcome back to
another video. In this one, my friends,
I'm finally going to be testing the
Radian
RX970 in 20 popular titles. Oh yeah.
Going over its specs first. This is an
RDNA 4.0 architecture GPU. It has
3,584 shading units, 224
TMUs, 128 ROPS, 56 RT cores, and the RT
performance has improved quite a lot
compared to the last generation on AMD
cards. Then it also features 16 GB of
GDDR6 memory. You know, the correct
amount for a $550 GPU. And it's also
running on a 256-bit memory bus with a
bandwidth of
644.6 GB per second. It also features
PCI Express 5.0* 16. And I really like
this part, guys. It has double 8 pin
power connectors because it's a 220 watt
TDP GPU. However, this one is the power
hellhound version. And in its OC mode,
which is how it comes out of the box, it
actually consumes a little bit more at
230 W. Still pretty efficient as you'll
see for the performance it gets. Now, as
I said, the MSRP of this GPU is
$550. That's the exact same as the RTX
5070, which is a little bit slower, like
around 9 10% slower at 1440p resolution,
which I'll be testing this on. And the
Nvidia GPU also only has 12 GB of VRAM
instead of the 16 that you get over
here. So, it looks like you get a decent
deal over here compared to that GPU,
right? But then you remember that the XT
version is only $50 more expensive. And
I guess that's the one to get. But hey,
that's enough intro. Let's put this
thing to the test at 1440p resolution,
shall we? And first up, we got Cyberpunk
2077. Look at this, guys. looking
beautiful. Buttery smooth with 100 plus
frames per second at the start. Damn.
All right, we're playing at 1440p
resolution utilizing the ultra settings
preset without FSR and without these
options right here. This is native 1440p
ultra. No rate tracing yet. I will try
it out a little bit later, of course. Uh
but yeah, it still looks really, really
good here on the ultra settings. Even
without the rate tracing, we still got
some decent looking reflections,
although not accurate ones. Uh, but
yeah, the overall presentation of the
game here at 1440p ultra settings is
really gorgeous. And we're getting
around 100fps average, so that is also
absolutely amazing. Of course, buttery
buttery smooth. In terms of how it
compares with the RTX 5070, I see that
it's around like five to six FPS faster
here in my benchmark run. Goodbye, Bob.
Did you do that on purpose? He asked. Oh
boy, he's still not used to it. Is he?
Anyway, around here. Yeah, the 5070 was
actually dropping into the 80s. This one
is only dropping into the lower 90s
around the roundabout here. So, yes,
this is slightly faster than the RTX
5070 in Cyberpunk. There is absolutely
no need to utilize upscaling here at
native resolution with the ultra
settings. So, as long as you keep that
rate tracing off, it's going to be
buttery smooth. Really nice. But let's
try it with that rate tracing, shall we?
So, I'm going to use rate tracing ultra
here. Disable resolution scaling al
together first so we can see the native
resolution results. Disable these
options here as well. And I will restart
the game to make sure it fully applies.
And here we have it, guys. Great racing
ultra preset at 1440p native resolution.
It's nothing amazing obviously. I mean
you lose a ton of performance compared
to the ultra preset without rate tracing
here but it is actually super similar to
what the RTX 5070 its competitor on the
green side uh did in this title that was
also getting around 40ish frames per
second on average. Now, where they
haven't closed the gap, especially in
Cyberpunk 2077, or particularly in
Cyberpunk, and goodbye Bob, by the way,
is in terms of the upscaling, guys,
because this game still doesn't support
a good form of upscaling for AMD GPUs.
So, we got FSR 2.1, FSR 3, which is
worse than 2.1 in this title, and XSS
1.3. Now, I'm going to use FSR 2.1
quality first, and uh you can see a
totally different look to the game
already. It's very shimmery. It has a
ton of pixelation. It has ghosting
around the car and on the back of the
car as well. If you look look at the
wheels, for example, there. Uh yeah,
it's it's not a good look, guys.
Honestly, it does improve our FPS by a
whole lot. It's 60 plus all of the time
at the moment. So, it's doing a great
job at that. But in terms of the
upscaler quality itself, the LSS4 is way
above what this does. I mean, it's FSR
2.1 after all. And AMD has FSR4, but
it's not available in this title,
unfortunately. If I go here to the
Radian settings, it shows no FSR4
support in this title. So, yeah, guys,
it's a bit of a shame. I really hope the
developers of this game actually
implement FSR4 into it or that or maybe
AMD actually makes a driver update that
makes support for this game as well to
override it with the LSS4. Uh now this
is XSS ultra quality. Still looks very
shimmery to my eyes and I'm using a
1440p monitor here at 24 in. So the PPI
is higher than it would be on a 27 in
monitor and it's really shimmery anyway.
So, uh, yeah, even with XSS, it's not a
good look, guys. So, yeah, if you want
to play with rate tracing, I think I
would wait for them to implement FSR4
into the game or for AMD to release a
driver update to override the FSR4
inside of this title. You know what,
guys? I have intrusive thoughts now. I
want to do rate tracing overdrive native
resolution first, okay? Just to see how
it looks. And oh boy. Okay, 20fps. It
drops into the teens at times.
Obviously, this is completely
unplayable. It's also unplayable on the
RTX 5070, but AMD GPUs seem to be a
little bit more hit with the path
tracing than the Nvidia counterparts.
But obviously, the the path tracing
stuff is absolutely unplayable without
the help of upscaling on either GPUs and
on this tier of GPUs as well. It's just
completely awful. Basically, let's
enable FSR quality here, please. Oh,
thank God it gets 30 FPS. Okay, that's
much better. Still not a viable option
in my opinion. Uh, I think you should
utilize 1440p ultra settings and call it
a day here. It's going to be buttery
smooth as you saw, 100 fps and a really
nice experience and gorgeous one at the
same time. I wouldn't really utilize
rate tracing until they add FSR4 into
this game. Next up is the recently
released on PC, The Last of Us Part Two
Remastered, guys. And this one is
looking absolutely gorgeous at 1440p
resolution with FSR4. I did the override
thingy where you press Alt R inside of
the game and go to the Radian settings
right here. Enable FSR4 super resolution
and then restart the game to fully apply
it. And now we have it here showing up
in the menu. And this is by far the best
anti-aliasing available for this GPU.
And over here you can see that I have
everything maxed out aside from the
motion blur intensity as well as
chromatic aberrations and stuff like
that. And we lose about like six frames
per second, five or six frames per
second compared to TAA here by the use
of FSR4 native AA. But it's not smudgy
like TAA is super blurry and stuff, you
know, and it's not pixelated like the
FSR 3.1 native AA is. This is doing a
fantastic job. It's buttery smooth as
well. It's maxed out settings at 1440p,
so it's beautiful. Even though this is a
PS4 game, you know, a PlayStation game
that released years ago, it still looks
phenomenal on PC. And if you have a
recent GPU, it also plays really, really
well. Now we're dropping into the 70s
here, but this is one of the most
intensive areas in the game. Actually,
this super dense forest area. It might
drop here and there. Actually, I've seen
one area where it drops a little bit
more than this, but it will never drop
from 60 frames per second. We're well
above that on average, as you can see
there. But let's turn on that FSR frame
generation now along with AMD anti-lag 2
to lower down that latency that comes
with frame generation. And here, yeah,
things are looking really similar. Maybe
slightly softer, but it's really hard to
tell, actually. And now it's an ultra
smooth experience, guys. I mean, you
could actually max out a 165 Hz monitor
at times uh with these settings. So,
yeah, if you prefer the native results,
80 fps or 80 to 90 most of the time is
absolutely great of an experience
already. But if you have a high refresh
rate monitor, phenomenal experience here
actually. And let's move on to the next
one. Now, it's a competitive shooter.
Counterstrike 2 at 1440p using very high
settings with four times MSAA to max out
the GPU all of the time. Okay, here we
go. It seems like it's very similar to
what the 4070 Super did or the 5070 in
this title. Both of those GPUs are very
similar anyways. And uh this is just
that with 16 GB of VRAM it seems like at
least so far. Not too bad. You know,
it's still slightly faster most of the
time than the 5070, but it's not by
much. All right. All right. We got these
guys. Fourth place.
No. That was close. That was close
there. Probably just ping, right? It's
never my fault. Yeah, guys. The overall
experience is really dang smooth. We got
anti- lag 2 enabled here as well, which
makes everything really snappy and
feeling very snappy. Uh, that's awesome.
That's exactly what we want, obviously,
on a competitive shooter title like
Counter Strike. And the FPS are super
high, so it's going to be a buttery
smooth experience. Yeah, almost got that
one. Come on. All right. Where are the
guys? Maybe he killed the other one. I
don't know.
Okay, got another escape up. Okay, you
know what, guys? Maybe I should go with
the AK47 cuz I'm feeling that today.
There, there it is. Also feeling the
AWP. We're doing some great shots today.
Okay, I know there is an AWP guy. Yes,
there he is. Okay, another one down.
Good stuff. Good stuff. Let's keep on
going here. No problems. Yes, that guy
was hearing us.
Okay, all good. One
bullet. Yes. I was dreaming a little bit
there. Come on. Come on. Come on. One
more. One more. No, not this one.
Freaking protect. We got five kills
there with head shot, but then I needed
to reload. And one second left. We
finished second place. Not bad at all,
though. That was really nice. Now, it's
my favorite game coming out this year so
far. Kingdom Come Deliverance
2. And we're playing this one at the
1440p resolution using ultra settings,
FSR native AA enabled. And I am
overwriting that with FSR4 over here on
the Radian settings as you can see. And
compared to the RTX 5070 or 4070 Super
from last generation, this is basically
the same performance. It's actually a
little bit slower than the 5070 here.
Still providing an awesome experience.
Of course, it's well above 60 FPS all of
the time. I'm going into a forest area
in just a little bit. Dropping into the
70s there. Hm. 69 1% lows. Nice. But
yeah, guys, I mean, price performance
ratio, it's probably reasonable for this
generation, but if you compare it to
last generation's cards, 4070 Super was
already providing around this
performance. 7900 GRE as well, uh,
somewhat, you know, so it's not really
that amazing really. Uh, the amazing
part that comes with this GPU in
particular is FSR4, which is a major
improvement over FSR3. It's also a
little bit more intensive, so it's
dropping our FPS here slightly, but I
would utilize it cuz again, it looks
quite a bit better. But again, I feel I
still feel like these GPUs should be a
little bit cheaper than they are,
especially for this card in particular,
only being 50 bucks less expensive than
the XT variant, which is quite a bit
faster. Still, it can provide an awesome
uh experience here at 1440p resolution.
As you can see, you could utilize like
FSR quality if you really want to push
things up a little bit in terms of
performance, but it stays above 60 like
99% of the time. You shouldn't really
worry about that too much. But I'm still
going to try that quality FSR. Just
going to add just a little bit of
sharpness there. And this is FSR4 on
quality. And it's the first time that
I'm seeing FSR4 quality in this
particular title. It pushes things up
into the 100s in terms of performance
and FPS. That's quite nice. It was
dropping to 70s 60s around here and now
it's buttery smooth. And in terms of
sharpness, since I added that little bit
of sharpness in the slider, it's really
good looking. I don't have a problem
with this whatsoever. It looks really
similar to 1440p native resolution. like
this is a first impression here of FSR4
quality in this particular title that
I'm doing and I would definitely not
mind playing like this. So yeah, great
stuff here. Kingdom Come: Deliverance 2
is an awesome title. I totally recommend
it. There's no stuttering. It's great
looking and it has physics like this.
It's awesome. Right now it's Forza
Horizon 5. This game is extremely well
optimized and beautiful as well. Oh,
look at these graphics. I mean, 150 fps
and we're using 1440p resolution with
TAA and the maximum settings. All right,
I manually set everything to the
absolute maximum here. Start counting
our frames.
160s. Beautiful, buttery smooth, high
refresh rate experience. That's what I
love to see. And that is kind of what
we've lost in recent years, guys. Aside
from like the odd game here and there,
Kingdom Come: Deliverance 2 for example,
being very smooth, most games these days
are never going to reach 160 FPS with uh
9070 level of GPU performance or 5070
GPU performance without frame
generation, anything like that and
upscaling. Whoop! No. No. We lost our
spoiler. I don't want to drive this
without a spoiler. Let's go back. There
we go. We're fine. We're fine
approaching the city this time and 130s
once again. So, it drops to about the
same values as inside of bushes and
stuff. Uh, low 130s, but it's still a
super high refresh rate experience all
of the time. No doubt about it. This is
amazing. This game also doesn't really
have uh any problems with like TAA
blurriness and stuff. So, no need to use
FSR native AA and stuff like that. The
TAA implementation here is wonderful.
and it drops down to 118 FPS absolute
minimum cuz the tunnel area is actually
the most intensive area inside of the
entire game. So yeah, it's a flawless
experience in Forza Horizon 5 from one
of the best optimized titles to one of
the worst ones. Then we got Elder
Scrolls for Oblivion at 1440p resolution
using high settings. I did disable lumen
hardware rate tracing and I'm using
software rate tracing on low because you
know that's really intensive and the
upscaling is set to native AA with FSR4
as you can see in the radian settings
and with these settings we can actually
achieve 60 plus FPS most of the time. I
mean, you do lose a little bit of visual
quality by not going with uh the
hardware rate tracing set to high for
example instead. But then you'd be at
like 50 to 60 frames per second as well.
So to keep it above 60 frames all of the
time with stutters cuz stutters are a
part of UE5 and this is based on UE5.
You'll need to utilize these settings.
High still looks really good, so that's
not really that big of an issue. Oh my
god. Why? Why are you after me? I'm here
with Roach. Stop hitting my roach,
please. 69 FPS, by the way. Uh, but
yeah, why? Why? Why? Also, that water
looks pretty
terrible. I mean, yeah, look at that.
That's where the high rate racing,
hardware rate racing comes into play. It
makes the water look a lot better. But,
but oh my gosh, this guy is actually
hitting us now. Okay, he's a bad boy.
Come on. Come on, Roach. Let's go. Let's
go. Let's get out of here, buddy. Also,
around here, it's dropping into the low
60s at times. Uh, okay. And it even
drops into the 50s, so it's not going to
be stable fully at 60 plus 100% of the
time, and it's a big disappointment. But
again, it just comes down to the
optimization in this game not being
there. Now, it's Call of Duty War Zone.
We're playing at 1440p using the extreme
settings preset. I'm just going to
disable the depth of field. This is it.
Oh, just in time. And here we go.
Looking at the entire map from above.
We're getting very high refresh rate
experience here. 140 FPS plus all of the
time. And in this game, the Radian GPUs
actually perform incredibly well
compared to the Nvidia counterparts. It
really likes AMD GPUs. And uh well,
that's great. With the 9070 over here,
you can expect a really nice and buttery
smooth experience all of the time, even
on extreme settings preset. This is not
the maximum settings inside of this
game, by the way. But it looks pretty
much the same. And I mean, those FPS are
just amazing, of course. So, no problems
here. Okay, we got a couple of them
here. They also got us. Uh, zooming in
drops our FPS by quite a lot. As you can
see, we're getting 160s. Zooming in puts
us in the 120s. That's that's a big drop
there, but not really that noticeable.
Even on a higher refresh rate panel, it
still feels incredibly smooth, of
course. And I really like the fact that
they got this map back into the game.
It's looking great as well with the
graphical tweaks that they made. The
lighting and stuff reminds me kind of
Battlefield 4, you know, that was
awesome. And uh yeah, we can actually
have an awesome experience here. Where
where's the bastard? Okay, come on. No
shields on him. Come on. Okay, I'm
trying to Oh, hello. There's a guy here.
Oh boy. Oh boy. Let's be careful. Let's
be careful. There he is. Got him. Good,
good, good, good. There's another
one. Why am I not expecting another one
at the same place
ever? Now it's Alan Wake 2. And this is
quite a bit faster than the RTX 5070
here as well. I am very impressed about
it. We're at 1440p native resolution
utilizing maximum settings here aside
from the rate racing which is turned
off. And let's start counting our FPS.
We're around 60 fps and the 5070 was
getting low 50s at the start there. Now
this is dropping into the 40s and 50s of
course because this area is more
intensive. But still, it's a little bit
of a difference there compared to the
other GPU from Nvidia. And uh it's nice
increase in performance about like 10%.
I think the thing is obviously this is
still not a perfect experience. It drops
from 60 fps very often. So you might as
well just play on like high settings
instead of maximum settings in this
title or utilize some upscaling. Now,
thankfully, this is probably the best
implementation of FSR2 that I have ever
seen so far. It gets just a little bit
softer, but it still looks really good.
There's no major pixelation or
shimmering here. In the finer branches
over here, you can actually tell a
little bit of noise, but it's really
minor. It's again the best
implementation that I've seen with FSR2
enabled. And it's also enough to put us
above 60 fps all of the time, which is
quite nice as well. Even here in this
area, it only drops into the 70s. And
again, it looks really similar to the
native resolution stuff, even though
it's FSR2. So, super impressed with this
implementation, actually. There's also
no FSR4 override, which is a little bit
of a shame in this title, guys. I would
like to have seen that, but I guess
developers need to implement it, or
maybe AMD needs to push more driver
updates to uh update more games with
FSR4's override. I don't know. Now, what
about that rate tracing though? Let's
try using medium RT here, which sets
path tracing to medium as well. Very
intensive stuff. And even with the FSR
quality, yep, it's it's not happening
here, guys. Path tracing is really
demanding. And even the upscaler doesn't
really save it. As you can see, it's
dropping into the low30s at times. It's
also going above 12 GB of VRAM
allocation, by the way. So that's
interesting to see as well. Um, so
having 16 GB does make a little bit of a
difference there. So yeah, it's not
amazing, guys. If it had FSR4, it would
probably have been a lot better than
this. But, uh, yeah, as it stands, I
would stay away from rate tracing in
this one. Even with the high settings
instead of max settings plus RT enabled
on medium doesn't really change things
by much. Thankfully, this still looks
very good without rate tracing and you
can achieve way higher FPS. Damn, this
is high settings with FSR2 and no RT and
it it gets 100 plus. Jesus, that's a
major increase in performance. Holy
crap. Let me see it at native resolution
using the high settings preset.
Actually, there's no need to restart the
game, by the way, to apply these
settings. I'm also noticing that this
isn't as sharp of an image quality as
with DAA on the Nvidia side of things,
but they do have the LSS4 implemented in
this game already. And we only have FSR2
here and FSR2 native AA, so obviously
it's going to look worse. But you do
have AFMF2 as well, which I mean is
frame generation through the driver. So,
let's try that out actually. And yep, I
can notice it is smoother at the moment,
but we can't really see the FPS from
AFMF2 inside of MSI After Burner. So, we
actually need to bring up the radian
overlay there to see the actual FPS that
are being displayed on the monitor now.
And it's
around 130 140 as you can see. That's
pretty crazy. It feels really smooth at
the moment. Input lag is minimal really.
And you know what? Let's select the
quality FSR again with the rate tracing
on medium and AFMF2 at the same time.
Frame gen through the driver. It's a
little bit softer, instantly noticeable.
It's actually really noisy around the
character now. Yeah, I mean driverbased
FG isn't really that amazing in terms of
picture quality. Has a lot of artifacts.
It's nice to have, but I wouldn't use
it. And uh I wouldn't use rate racing
whatsoever in this title with a
9070. Next up, we got Rockstar's
masterpiece, my friends. Red Dead
Redemption 2. Buttery smooth here with
100 FPS to start this off. And we're
playing at 1440p resolution using
maximum settings aside from a couple of
them. The water physics is not maxed out
and the three tessillation is turned
off. These are extremely demanding
settings. And well, if you turn those
off, the game will look basically the
same as completely maxed out and you
gain quite a lot of FPS. Now, in terms
of anti-aliasing, this is where this
kind of sucks a little bit because
you're stuck with TAA or MSAA. MSAA
being super demanding in this title. So,
yeah, it will wreck your FPS. Not really
the perfect AA solution. And TAA being
really, really soft. It pretty much
sucks basically, you know. Now, you can
still play the game like this. A ton of
people already enjoyed Red Dead
Redemption 2 with TAA, but on Nvidia
GPUs and with the RTX 5070, I actually
tried it with the LAA, and I overrode
the LSS with the LAA um and the LSS4 as
well, and that provides a much cleaner
picture quality in Red Dead Redemption
2. I've seen the other side, you know.
I've seen Red Dead Redemption 2 the
crispiest that it can get and it this is
not it. Anyway, let's go with Bob here.
Sing for us, Bob, so we can feel more
happy,
please. Beautiful. Thank you. Finally,
we're in Strawberry Town, which is
pretty demanding of an area here, and
it's only dropping into what, the ' 90s.
We got a little stutter so far. That
will happen more often in Saint Deni, by
the way, especially during nighttime.
But FPS are actually very similar to
what we see here. But yeah, it's an
almost flawless experience. It's almost
as good as it gets here in Red Dead
Redemption 2 at 1440p resolution. So no
complaints here, but that anti-aliasing
from the game. Now we got another huge
game from Rockstar, GTA 5. This is the
enhanced edition at 1440p. Very high
rate racing settings with FSR3 native
AA. Couldn't override it with FSR4, but
it still looks really good this way. And
we get around 100 plus FPS inside. I
guess it's going to be 100 plus FPS on
average, honestly. Let's start counting
the frame rates as well. And yeah, it's
buttery smooth, guys. To be expected,
this is with rate racing as well. But
this GPU handles rate racing pretty
well. All right, now we're going to see
some Bob's friends. All of these are
Bob's friends. Oh, wait a second. Oh,
come on. All right, that was barely a
hit. Oh, sorry. Sorry people. Sorry. All
right. I tried. I was really trying not
to hit anyone, but I don't care anymore.
And here we go, my friends. We're almost
there. Oh, it opened our um trunk. Okay.
Interesting. Or it's maybe not the trunk
because the the motor is actually there
right on this car. Oh, come on, buddy.
Please. Oh, no. We're going to miss
Jack, dude. Seriously, please Jack, be
there. We took way too long. Anyway,
dropping into the 90s around here.
Hello, Jack. How we going? He waited for
us thankfully. Oh, boy. How's it going,
buddy? Can you talk to
us? Look at that. Look at that.
Beautiful. All right, my friends. So,
even here inside of Bob's bushes and
stuff like that, which is down here, by
the way. Shouldn't drop too much. All
right. Into the 80s, as you can see,
even 70s at times. So, pretty intensive
stuff. And goodbye, Bob. Hey, there we
go. It is extremely nice of an
experience with the rate racing enabled
as well. And this is native resolution.
No need to utilize any upscalers at all
or frame generation or AFMF2 through the
drivers and stuff. This game doesn't
support FG by the way. Um, so yeah, just
set it to very high rate raising
settings and forget it. It's going to be
perfect. And by the way, on maximum RT
settings, I tried it for a little bit.
It was down into the 60s and 70s,
sometimes 50s, so I wouldn't touch that.
This is already good enough. It looks
basically the same as maximum. So, these
are the settings to go with with the
9070. Next, we got Indiana Jones and the
Great Circle at 1440p using the Supreme
settings preset. No path tracing yet.
Okay, I'll try it later. And native
resolution, guys. And uh well, it gets
us 80s as you can see with the R LOD
scale set to five. So, we don't have
pop-in issues. Actually, it looks way
better like this. and it stays at 60
plus FPS pretty much at all times. Let's
run around here for a little bit. Go
into the next section of this area in
Peru. This is exactly where we start
actually inside of this title. So, I'm
not giving you spoilers or anything. All
right, but do make sure that you use the
R LOD scale 5 in the console because
otherwise it will look really bad with a
lot of popping issues and stuff which uh
are actually kind of fixed by the use of
path tracing. But path tracing is way
too intensive for this card. It's also
way too intensive for some other cards
on the green team like the 5070 and the
4070 Super and stuff like that. It's
just wrecks FPS every single time. So,
it's not really ideal. I think these are
the adequate settings for a card in this
performance tier. But if you want to dip
your toes into some path tracing, guys,
well, let's check it out over here with
these settings. It never drops from 60.
You keep the native resolution. So,
that's nice. And that's what I utilize.
But let's use like low path tracing
here. Look at that VRAMm usage. By the
way, the allocation 15 GB. This is where
the 5070 struggles a lot because it runs
out of VRAM and we'd need to drop down
like the textures for example for it to
stay relevant. So having 16 GB very nice
here but the performance with path
tracing is very poor as you can see 30
fps still at native resolution so that's
expected of course from path tracing
here. Uh the frame time is so weird
actually it's all over the place there.
So to utilize path tracing properly
here, you'd need to utilize some FSR as
well, like quality FSR. Even then 20s,
yeah, it's not going to happen, guys,
with a
970. What about like performance FSR?
Will it save it? No, not really. Still
around the same thing with worse
visuals, of course. And actually
enabling FSR also enables frame
generation. here the options. So, we do
have frame generation after all. That's
nice to see, but it's not enough to uh
make it playable, of course. First of
all, that frame time has some weird
stuff happening. What the What was that?
Second of all, now with the frame
generation enabled, since the baseline
FPS were so low, there is a freak ton of
input lag, so it's not playable. So,
stay away from path racing with this
GPU. Next up, we got Stalker 2. an
extremely intensive title based on UE5
once again uh with lumen and stuff and
it seems like it's getting exactly the
same FPS as the RTX 5070 did. Uh we're
playing here with the same settings as
that GPU 1440p resolution epic settings
preset FSR native AA but I have overrode
it in the Radian settings to FSR4. So
we're using FSR4 here and like this it
looks just as good as the LAA. It's a
really nice um anti-aliasing in this
title. It provides much better image
quality than with FSR 3.1, which is the
normal FSR for this title once again.
So, I highly recommend you to enable
FSR4 in the Radian settings for this one
to use as native AA because if you want
to use the upscaler, there is a bit of
an issue with it in this title. I've
also noticed that with Oblivion in the
full video for Oblivion that I made on
the
RX970 and FSR4 just has some trouble
with Unreal Engine's vegetation it seems
like. So if I stand right here for
example, we're getting 60 fps. Not too
bad. You know, for a first-person
shooter, I'd like to see 60 plus all
over the time and for the price of the
GPU as well, but it is what it is. Um,
let's go use quality FSR here. And
again, this is FSR4 as you can see. And
uh well, at first glance it looks like
it's doing a decent job. But if you look
closely and if I do this real quick, see
that? See the amount of noise on the
vegetation
here. It's really crazy. And it's very
noticeable. Sometimes it will take a
while to disappear as well. over here on
these bushes. It's super pixelated and
noisy. I mean, over here it looks great,
but as soon as you turn your camera
around like this, see
that? It's awful. The FPS numbers are
actually really good. So, it's a good
improvement there. But FSR4 with
vegetation in UE5, it's just not having
it. I've tested two games so far, two
UE5 games with FSR4, and it doesn't work
properly here. So, that's a big shame.
So, what you need to do to achieve 60
plus FPS all of the time while keeping
the epic settings is enable some frame
generation. The baseline FPS with FSR
native AA were at around 60, you know,
on average. So, that's a good baseline
to enable frame generation on top of.
And when you do so, you get up into the
100s. Around this area, it would drop
into the 50s previously. So, you can
notice a little bit more latency
creeping into the picture here. Well,
not the picture, but you can feel the
latency with your mouse, right? But
outside of here, while you're shooting
things and stuff, and even here,
honestly, if you want to shoot Bob in
the face, for example, um there he is.
Wait a second. Goodbye,
Bob. You can definitely do that and
achieve a good experience here in
Stalker 2. Again, there is a bit of
input lag.
That was a massive stutter. U5 guys, it
was way too smooth. You know, I was
actually going to comment on that. This
is way flatter of a frame time graph
without the frame generation than the
RTX 5070s frame time graph in this game.
And that's something that I also saw in
Oblivion. You know, I feel like UE5
titles tend to have a little bit of a
flatter frame time on these Radon 9000
series cards. That's pretty good. But
hey, most of the time, like 98% of the
time, it's going to be a smooth
experience here. Still adequately
responsive in my opinion. You can feel
the input lag once again, but you can
get used to it instantly. Like in 10
seconds, I'm used to it. And uh yeah, it
looks great at the same time on epic
settings with FSR4 native AA. And now
we're playing some Battlefield. Not the
best Battlefield title, unfortunately,
but it's the latest one. And we're
playing at 1440p resolution using the
ultra settings here with no rate racing
or dynamic resolution scale. It's full
resolution here. And uh let's start
counting our FPS. Try to get a few more
kills around here. Not too bad. Hey,
come on. Get that guy. There we go. Good
stuff. All right. Wait a second. Get
another one there. All right. I know
there's another one in that building.
Yeah, there he is. Gosh, that was too
late. All right, let's reload and start
pushing them over here on A2. Let's do
this. Okay. Okay. Okay. Sniper guy over
there. All right. All right. Uh go from
behind. Yes. Flank them bastards a
little bit here. Come on. What is that
dude?
Okay. I thought that was an enemy guy
there. All right. All good. All good. I
like this game, guys. You know, it's not
the best Battlefield once again, but
it's still a lot of fun to play. Just
not as good as the
others from
behind. Come
on. I throw a grenade. Let's go. Okay.
Okay. Sniper bastards
everywhere. That was terrible. Let's
push them. Let's push
them.
Nice. Nice. Nope. No. No. No. Nope. So,
well guys, I got no complaints here when
it comes to the performance in
Battlefield 2042. Absolute buttery
smooth experience. Was going to go for a
great play there. Yeah, 180 FPS average
almost. Pretty good stuff. Next up is
Horizon Forbidden West. We're playing at
1440p resolution using FSR native AA and
I did the overwrite thingy. So, we're
using it with FSR4 and on maximum
settings, which is basically a very high
with an isotropic filtering set to 16
times. And uh well, it does quite a bit
better of a job than say the RTX 5070 in
this particular title. I'm not sure if
it's because the 570 runs out of VRAM
and it lowers performance because of
that because this GPU is actually
consuming 13 gigabytes or not consuming
allocating 13 GB but that's the number
that we should go by not really the
usage there under it in some games the
allocation matters more than the usage
this is one of them and yeah it's
holding 100 FPS on average well as I say
that it drops to 99 but it's a much
smoother experience than the 5070 which
got 83 FPS average. And over here, if
you wanted to utilize some frame
generation, let's use it over native
resolution cuz baseline FPS were amazing
already. You can do so absolutely fine.
VRAMm increases by a little bit, but we
still have some headroom there. And now
we're getting 160s, 150s. A true buttery
smooth experience here for a high
refresh rate monitor. So that is really
awesome to see. and Nvidia are the ones
who made frame generation in the first
place. They kind of invented it, right?
Yet, they put so little VRAM on their
GPUs that it ends up not being as
usable. But obviously, the Nvidia GPU
also has other advantages like the LSS4
uh wider support for that as well. Yeah.
Anyway, tradeoffs here and there for
either team here really. And before we
go to the conclusion, and I'll have more
games there, so don't go anywhere. We
got Fortnite at 1440p using DirectX12
and the epic settings without nanite or
lumen at the moment. What is going on?
What is that? What? Okay, we got to
check that out, guys. Well, good thing
it's also inside of a big forest area
with a lot of vegetation. That should be
very GPU intensive. Really smooth
experience right now, actually. I'm
going to start counting the FPS and
let's check this out. The game still
looks really good even though we're not
utilizing hardware rate tracing or Lumen
at the moment. Okay, some people are
actually killing that guy over there.
Who is killing him? That's not a person,
is it? Or maybe it is a
player. All right. Yes, it's a player.
Okay, we got him. Good stuff. How did he
not kill me? I have no idea. And the
thing is gone at this point. What? No,
it was like a portal or something,
right? But guys, I'm really surprised
about the lack of stuttering at the
moment. That's the most surprising
thing. I even call this stutter night
sometimes instead of Fortnite, right?
And uh we're here running really fast
with this thing. We got a car actually.
So, let's check it out inside of the car
driving around. But so far so good.
Those 1% lows are super stable. I am
liking this experience here. But what if
you do like Stutter Knight and the
stutters that come with it? Well, I got
you covered then. We're at 1440p DX12
using the epic preset this time around,
which enables Nanite and Lumen.
Honestly, guys, this is still super
decent. I did not see that coming. This
is maxed out now. Did they improve
stability in this game? Probably, right?
See that we touch the ground. Frame
times are still flat. I am
so confused. Are we actually playing
Fortnite now? How come it's Unreal
Engine 5? Come on. There we go. I just I
like um sending those guys flying onto
the sky and stuff. It's so funny
actually. Uh wait a second. Maybe we
should uh just kill this guy. Maybe.
Yes. I can definitely feel the slowdown
compared to what we saw previously,
guys. It's not as smooth. It's not as
responsive turning the camera around and
stuff, especially closer to 60fps. Yeah,
with RT, you likely want to utilize some
TSR or maybe even XSS. Yeah, probably
XSS. Let's do ultra quality XSS. And
we're still using rate tracing as well.
And the graphics quality is still pretty
good. I can tell that like the grass and
stuff like that is a little bit more
fuzzy here. There's some noise, some
softness issue. Um, but you do get way
higher FPS at the same time. So, if
you're using RT, I think I will
recommend it with some XSS on top of it.
Still looks great. And now you got the
best lighting there is in this title.
Not bad. And it is conclusion time, my
friends. I'll still have five more games
running right here while we talk a
little bit about the pros and cons of
the
RX970. So, on the good side of things,
this is a very efficient GPU. It can be
undervolted and achieve pretty much the
same performance with much less power
consumption, which is really nice. A lot
of people are actually doing that. And
also, it can be overclocked and achieve
a little bit higher performance as well.
Uh, but that's the same thing for pretty
much all of the GPUs out there in the
market right now this generation. Still,
when compared to like the 5070 or even
the XT variant of the 9070 here, it is
more efficient than both of those GPUs.
It also provided really good 1440p
performance. As you saw, it's a fast
1440p gamer here. It runs even really
intensive titles at like high or ultra
settings at 1440p native resolution
without the need of utilizing upscaling.
And for some reason, it's the smoothest
GPU that I've tried so far in Unreal
Engine 5 titles. Another great
improvement over the 7900 GRE GPU, which
this is replacing at the same price
point, uh is the rate tracing
performance. AMD actually did it right
this time and it's much closer to the
RTX 5070 which is its true competitor in
price than in previous generations right
and then it also has four more gigabytes
of VRAM than the competition which I
feel like it's the adequate VRAM for
this price point and the 5070 should
have had 16 GB. Now, where the Nvidia
GPUs still have a big advantage in my
opinion is with
DLSS4 because FSR4 is actually really
great when it works right and as an
anti-aliasing. It works wonders. It's
really close to DAA stuff that you get
on Nvidia GPUs. I have no problems using
it and this can actually use that
absolutely fine at 1440p resolution but
it needs to be available in more titles
and the override needs to work a little
bit better in terms of the upscaler
because I have seen some issues like it
seems like EI5 titles have issues with
vegetation especially when it comes to
FSR4 but if they manage to fix that
shimmering issue and implement it in
more games FSR4 is a true competitor to
DLSS4. So, what should you buy? The
RX970 or the RTX 5070? I think this
provides a little bit better value at
the exact same price, same as MSRP
cards, you know, because of those 16 GB
of VRAM, slightly faster performance in
rasterization, although again rate
tracing is still a little bit faster on
a 5070. But if you want to do RT,
especially with upscaling, 5070 is the
way to go still. Even though it pains me
to say that because it's a 4070 Super,
you know, that released a year ago. Ah
boy, the improvements this generation
aren't really that big. Even this, you
know, compared to the 7900 GRE or the
4070 Super as well, it's not that much
faster, but at least it's a bigger
improvement because of rate tracing
performance compared to what the AMD had
previously basically. And also the
efficiency gains are definitely there
and are noticeable as well. Now, the big
problem is in my opinion, you should
neither get this or the 5070. you should
get just the 9070 XT which I haven't
tested yet but that has 5070 Ti
performance almost a little bit slower I
guess but talking MSRPs it's $50 more
than the 9070 over here so that's a
no-brainer and finally guys if you are
in Europe particularly in Spain Germany
or Portugal I have checked Amazon Spain
Amazon Germany and some local stores
here in Portugal and here the 570 seems
seems to be around 50
to€100 cheaper than this. So, I guess
here that's the best choice. I don't
know why these are so
expensive. I really don't want it to
fall. But yeah, the cheapest 9070 that I
saw was at
€710 and the cheapest 5070 that I saw
here was
€635. So that's quite a bit of a
difference there for GPUs that should be
priced the same. So basically it all
depends on price. It all depends on how
much you value 16 GB of VRAM and
efficiency here with this card in
particular and whether or not you care
about rate tracing a lot or you want to
play at native resolution or with
upscaling. So there's that my friends.
That's been it for this one. Thanks very
much for watching this video. I hope you
guys enjoyed it and I'll catch you in
the next one very soon. Expect a ton
more videos on the 9070 over here. And I
hope AMD sends the XT as well so we can
take a look. I'll catch you in the next
one. As always, love you all. Bye-bye.